quatrième cas d'espèce l'accueil des
bleus le 7 juillet là je veux vous dire
que cet accueil des bleus c'était un set
c'était un événement exceptionnel par sa
dimension et son ampleur qui a mobilisé
qui a mobilisé fortement la présidence
de république aux côtés des équipes de
la préfecture de police pour lequel il y
avait une manoeuvre complexe en matière
d'ordre public a organisé dans la
période que nous connaissons il n'est
pas du tout évident en terme de menaces
en termes d'ordre public de faire
circuler un bus de cette manière sur le
sur les champs-elysées donc j'ai
participé moi même les participants ou
les présidents et pas monsieur benalla à
l'organisation de cet événement cet
événement sans précédent est organisée
dans des délais très contraint je dois
vous dire que face à un tel évènement il
y avait à la fois à coordonner l'arrivée
d'une équipe de france qui était par
ailleurs relativement en retard sur le
planning qui était prévu et de l'autre
côté un événement complexe à organiser
au palais de l'elysée avec beaucoup de
jeunes puisque nous avons souhaité en
faire un événement de rencontre entre la
jeunesse et notre équipe de france
victorieuse
j'ai mobilisé deux de mes adjoints au
palais de l'elysée et j'ai demandé à
alexandre benalla d'être le garant de la
synchronisation de l'arrivée de ce but
c'est à dire qu'il était en contact avec
moi pour gérer cette synchronisation là
et je tiens j'avais tâche beaucoup
d'importance au terme de synchronisation
voilà les quatre cas d'espèce il ne
s'agit pas de déplacement officiel du
président de la république et donc je
considère que évidemment nous avons
appliqué la décision que nous avons
prise avec le directeur de cabinet et
que nous lui avons notifié le 23 mai au
matin